foreign
[Music]
the Hawaiian wind goddess wielded a
gourd that housed The Winds of the
islands it came to hold her bones along
with the life force They Carried and was
eventually passed to her grandson
he learned the hundreds of distinct
winds that wafted and whipped around his
homeland chanting their names he could
stir the skies and raise the waves like
his father before him he became the most
trusted attendant to King keave
of Hawaii island but his privileged
status also made him a Target two of the
king's seafaring Navigators were
especially envious they knew paca's
skills and responsibility to the king
were divinely inherited but they coveted
his position
so they whispered rumors and eventually
turned the king against his most loyal
companion
watched bitterly as he was stripped of
his land and privileges he fled Escaping
The Navigators who plotted to drown him
as he sailed away and took refuge on
Molokai where he married a young
chiefess they brought a son into the
world but pakha never stopped imagining
his return he taught his son
the way of the Winds until kwabaka was
poised to avenge his father and restore
his rightful place beside
back on Hawaii Island as the two
Navigators revealed their selfishness
the king realized how easily he'd been
deceived and longed for Paka some of his
more trustworthy attendants Divine that
Paka was still alive and told the king
to construct canoes for a journey
however Paka could not return so easily
first the King's loyalty and dedication
had to be
as the king rallied his attendance
ancestral Spirits arrived in the form of
two birds and rotted the trees he was
using for canoe buildings though
exhausted the king had his best archers
shoot the birds and he started again
later as Paka dreamed the king's Spirit
announced his search
however's own Spirit misled the king
saying he was on
the king's Fleet soon set sail as they
passed Molokai
greeted them warning that a storm was
brewing
chanted the names of the Winds but kept
his identity a secret as perpaka's plan
the king's Navigators dismissed the
young boy's claims but as they sailed
off
Unleashed a vicious storm and all were
forced to shelter on Molokai
for four months
maintained the storm with paka's secret
supervision he earned the king's trust
and after clearing the sky
agreed to join the king's search at Sea
the two Navigators continuously
discredited
finally he readied himself for revenge
and called the winds as waves crashed
anchored the canoe and passed Provisions
to everyone except the two Navigators
they grew calm and weak
eventually falling over
but Kwa paka's work wasn't done
while everyone slept he brightened the
sky and sailed towards Hawaii Island
instead of kahula though the king
regretted not finding parka everyone was
glad to be home and forgot about
until the day he proposed a canoe race
he wagered his catch of flying fish
against that of eight fishermen who had
been appointed by the two treacherous
Navigators they agreed figuring it'd be
an
[Music]
and a great wave whisked him ahead of
his opponents enraged and convinced this
was a fluke the fishermen asked for a
rematch but this time they demanded
wager his bones against theirs
first the men paddled fiercely with
kwapaka gliding effortlessly in their
wake
as they tired
hurdled himself to Victory
hearing that eight of his fishermen were
to Die the king asked to have mercy on
them but the time had come for kwapaka
to reveal his identity and have the king
prove his commitment to Paka
overcome the king agreed to their deaths
and asked to welcome a home promising
his lands and position would be restored
at last the king and pakkah were back at
each other's sides wielding the sacred
wind gourd pakha and guapaca ensured the
names of the Winds would never be lost
and those who understood them never
undermined
epic canoe voyages are very real parts
of Polynesian history learn how people
navigated to the Hawaiian islands and
across the Pacific for thousands of
years without modern navigational aids
with this video or learn how Hawaii was
illegally overthrown by the United
States with this one